[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
last year a whole bunch of hype started
building for this phone called the
Escobar phone which turned out just to
be a royal Flex pie folding phone with a
gold colored paint job that was clearly
BS people ordered the phone and never
got it then Flash Forward a couple
months later there was another one the
Escobar fold 2 and I did a video about
it at this point which was sort of going
over the whole idea that okay this now
is another phone we've already seen it's
the Samsung Galaxy fold with a gold
colored sticker on it and again the
people that ordered that phone they lost
their money and they never got it
so then fast forward again to a couple
days ago and I have an email in my inbox
from the Escobar guys says our latest
phone is scheduled to deliver to you
tomorrow we are doing a big launch
and then there's a DHL tracking number
but like
well I already made a video about how
you guys are scamming people and how you
shouldn't give them any of your money
and how you should direct your attention
to other things why would you willingly
send me another package
then again it is from the chief of
assassinations
maybe I maybe I shouldn't open this
but I did I opened it for you guys of
course here's what I found they're
basically doing the same thing yet again
but this time a little more Shameless
than before this one they're calling the
Escobar gold 11 Pro maybe you've seen
the headlines by now so I don't know
maybe I missed the Escobar gold 10 and
the Escobar gold nine whatever but right
at the top of the box is a very familiar
looking phone because it's an iPhone 11
Pro with some gold on it there's never
any confusion right like they we never
thought that the Escobar company was
making any sort of phone every single
one of these so far has been someone
else's phone with some gold wrapped
around it and stamping their logo on it
just so we're on the same page now this
one they're saying they plated in 24
Karat solid gold and you know what
honestly this appears to be true this
whole sticker thing was too easy to peel
off and notice apparently maybe my last
video sort of gave it away so now you
have this phone where apparently there's
some protective clear coating on top
that was easy for me to peel off and
then it is the actual back of the iPhone
but plated in a thin layer of something
metallic that appears to be gold now I
don't have my Jerry everything most pick
but gold is a soft metal scratches at a
level two with deeper grooves at a level
three so while it's clearly not a
sticker on the back of the phone here I
am able to actually scratch some of this
metal off and appears to just be flecks
of gold from my knife if you look into
it it's actually not that expensive to
coat something this size in a thin layer
of gold the escobars even say so on
their site something around like 50
bucks but anyway underneath the phone in
the box is this piece of paper here
labeled condition report which I'll get
to in a second and then the accessories
and that's it but see I don't want to
spend any more time on the product
because I feel like the more time we
spend on this gold phone the more we
lose sight of the bigger picture here
they're not going to ship you this
just like they didn't ship the fold one
or the fold two if you give them your
money you won't be getting this either
it's just marketing see if we take a
step back every company if you want to
call it that has a structure in place
and has a plan and the components around
it designed to make them money as much
money as they possibly can and so this
is another one of those businesses where
you know they've rinsed and repeated
this formula enough times that we can
see what their strategy is and if this
is the first time we're ever wrong about
it it's too late because this is the
face they've painted for themselves step
one
pick a desirable tech product and put it
on your website for a remarkably cheap
so whether it's a two thousand dollar
folding phone or a thousand dollar
iPhone doesn't really matter as long as
the price you list is way below what
you'd expect step two hype it up and
make up some sort of a story behind it
and I do this a lot this is where you
see all the wild videos on their various
YouTube channels and the unboxings with
the Escobar girls
etc etc buying ripapple.com and having
it redirect to their site you know
they're painting this whole image for
themselves along with the Escobar name
they even made this one limited edition
to Just 2 000 units and a story they're
pushing this time is that their
refurbished iPhones that they're buying
and fixing up with genuine Apple parts
and then coating them in gold and
shipping them it even comes with this
condition report like I mentioned
earlier that lists the parts of the
phone that were good and the parts of
the phone that were replaced fun fact a
rune from Mr who's the boss we've been
talking about this he also got one of
these and we compared our condition
reports for our phone phones say
different things this is actually
convincing it is very possible that
these are actually refurbished iPhones
now do I believe that Escobar Inc is the
one's refurbishing it
not really and also none of it matters
because they're not actually shipping it
step three marketing this is the part
where they send it to influencers to
YouTubers to just get it in front of
cameras get the Press wave going I
obviously didn't order this phone now
the key is to only ship out a few of
those to the people who you believe will
make the videos and we'll share it with
their audiences and things like that but
as long as that number of phones is
small and you ship them to the right
people those videos will generate more
sales that you never have to ship
and then as a bonus
since all press is good press
how about a little lawsuit with apple
you may have noticed a weird looking
paper at the top of the box in the
unboxing it's this dear buyer sheet and
a 14-page printout of a lawsuit
apparently filed by the U.S District
Court of Nevada for some reason I'll
spare you all the details of actually
reading all this because I did it for
you basically this one is a 14-page
lawsuit about them suing one of their
former employees for like stealing a
couple thousand bucks from them and the
YouTube channel I kind of believe that
and then this other one here this dear
buyer sheet includes a note about them
suing Apple for 2.6 billion dollars and
this is apparently because the the head
of assassinations was uh was using
FaceTime and there was a bug in FaceTime
that allowed someone to find his
location and so that caused him a lot of
distress and that person was trying to
kill him and so he had to sue Apple for
all the distress and all the money he
spent relocating and beefing up his
security as you can tell
I don't know if you're getting the
picture here but that's not worth two
billion dollars but for whatever reason
the media just loves reporting on this
they can't help themselves anyone suing
Apple is already kind of big clicks nice
juicy headline but for two billion
dollars and the escobars how exciting
but honestly this might be the smartest
thing they've ever done smarter than
just sending the phone to YouTubers
because you know what they don't expect
to win this lawsuit you don't expect do
you really expect Apple to settle for
two billion dollars for this random
company no
but you know what they do expect
press coverage and you know what else
these sites are putting in their
articles about this lawsuit
ripapple.com the Escobar gold iPhone
their brand new campaign the limited
edition it's free real estate step four
take people's money no refunds basically
once they've used all this press to get
people to their site finally and they've
riled people up with the Escobar name
and their crazy videos and the limited
edition counter then you'll notice if
you actually add this thing to your cart
and proceed to checkout the only payment
methods for this phone are a direct bank
transfer
cryptocurrency or a Western Union direct
bank transfer this should be just about
the biggest red flag ever they're hoping
you don't think too hard about it oh you
know it's the escobars they got their
whole crypto thing going on I don't know
but the whole point is these are all
non-refundable payment methods and so as
they take your money and then Dodge you
for a week some couple weeks couple
months couple years if they have to you
will never get your money back because
these are non-refundable payment methods
definitely check out Mr who's the boss
he's dropping a video at the same time
as this where he goes a little more into
the the company itself the Escobar Inc
people what they're up to and why they
actually ship books to people instead of
phones the facts are kind of interesting
there but to answer my question back at
the beginning of the video why did they
send me this package and this phone if
I've already made a video tearing them
down talking about how their phone is a
scam and the honest answer as dumb as it
sounds is they've probably done the math
and realized that this is still good
press for them when I put up my last
video a couple hours later it looked
like their site went down and we felt
like oh we can celebrate we actually
sort of took them down but no it was
really kind of just a hug of death when
too many people goes to a site and takes
down the server because they can't
handle that much traffic the site went
back up and maybe at least five or six
of you actually tried to give them money
to get a phone from seeing my video
about it so let me be perfectly clear in
this video if I haven't already gotten
the plan across
do not give them your money unless you
never want to see it again and never get
anything back for it but they're there
are much better uses of just giving away
money give it to charity give it to a
better cause right now
and uh don't pay any attention to this
Escobar Inc company as long as they keep
rinsing and repeating the same strategy
it's not worth paying attention to
there you have it
but if you do get super curious and just
want to visit their site I do advise
protecting yourself with the sponsor of
this video expressvpn so some of you
like to check the apps on my phone in
every video and if you have then you're
one of the people who's noticed
expressvpn on my phone so it's kind of
perfect that they're sponsoring this
video because they're all about internet
security and privacy and of course I've
tried other vpns in the past but if
you've listened to waveform you know
this is the one I've been using for a
while because the fastest one I've tried
and because they take their stuff very
seriously so we've all been spending a
lot more time on the internet lately me
too and when we do we start to realize
this process could be better
one example is when you're browsing the
internet from the comfort of your own
home your internet service provider
whether that's Verizon or comcast or
whoever they can see every single site
that you visit and that's whether you're
in incognito mode or you clear your
browsing history or whatever they can
see all that and they are legally
allowed to take that information and
sell it to advertisers to other
companies for profit so with expressvpn
they rewrite your connection through
secure encrypted servers so your ISP
cannot see what websites you're visiting
even if it is escobarink.com and the
cherry on top is you can change your
region to pretty much whatever region
you want whatever country you want so
think of all the different libraries on
all these different networks you just
unlocked on whether it's Netflix or Hulu
or BBC for that matter I've recently
been watching billions it's not
available at all on the US Netflix but
if I switch my location to Japan refresh
the page I can watch all the newest
stuff when it comes out so unlock
hundreds of new shows and content and
protect your privacy online will Express
yeah make sure you visit the link below
or go to expressvpn.com
MKBHD for three months free thanks again
to expressvpn for sponsoring this video
and I'll catch you guys in the next one
peace